Shayne Irving is here che how was the
offseason it awful Danny why awful but
that dude's got some pipes man what the
hell he did well yeah he did well
yeah right last year in your pics oh you
were 30 31 and 5 this is against the
spread
last week you went 4 and 1/4 to 4 and 2
on the Twitter okay you got picks this
week and then I'd like for you to give
us an assessment of what do you think is
going to happen with the Dallas Cowboys
that this season all right okay so you
think by the way Seton is said he's
putting money on your picks this year
big mistake
I thought we tried something new this
year well I'll open up an account
somewhere and we'll get a good money
okay I'll open it up in the bank of
shake and we'll just see what happens
okay a couple bucks down on each game
see what happens all right so your picks
for this week College pics or pro pics
or both college owns okay
okie light - 30 - Minnesota - one and a
half Georgia Tech - three BYU
- 3 and then Clemson - 12 against them
Aggies ok your Texas Longhorns come on
Danny this is this is the bigger problem
for me is this as opposed to the Cowboys
the Longhorns being this bad a football
for this long to me is unacceptable just
completely unacceptable you got more
money than anybody you got to recruit
sitting right there and you lose two
years in a row to Maryland to Maryland
and you don't even explain yourself to
the fan base you say oh we're too dumb
to figure out the improvements I count
two losses Danny against Maryland the
hill and Texas hurts you more than when
the Cowboys lose on a percent Jerry
Jones did something evil for those rings
I'm convinced and it might be a curse on
him maybe he's got to go before the
Cowboys win I don't know but it's a
popular theory the Longhorns ain't got
no curse Danny the Texas Longhorns were
talking college football you're not
gonna be patient with Tom Herman Oh what
would they be saying about what did they
say about Charlie Strong after starts
like this two years in a row they were
calling for his head quick ya know did
you bet so does Texas play this weekend
oh yeah and you're not you know you
messed on with the game they're like
minus 23 against
I ain't touching it no way I'd give me
an assessment of what you think is gonna
happen with the Dallas Cowboys you open
up with the Carolina Panthers I don't I
don't see how eight and eight eight
Nate's the best that this team could do
with the schedule they got and the
offensive game plan they gotta have to
do there's just no way there's no way
you don't have any receivers really that
are dynamic and can get open for dak
that's a problem with me the run game is
gonna work all day long but when they
put ten in the box we need somebody to
do a play-action or at least look off a
safety and it's throw a frickin strike
over the middle to a receiver who's that
gonna be Cole Beasley huh or screw Danny
but is there a part of you that wants
them to do poorly then you get the
ginger fired
ginger ain't going nowhere and even if
the ginger goes who they're gonna get
somebody else that's a puppet for Jerry
honestly who else would take that job
who was a good enough coach for us to be
happy about that harm unless Jerry is so
desperate to get back to the Super Bowl
that he sacrifices his ego and brings in
somebody that he truly let's run the
team if he can actually do that it's
probably the day he gets diagnosed with
dementia you need to keep it positive
it's September well you got a long year
man beginning of the pain right here
Danny how's the family by the way now
they're fine yeah yeah preschools all
that fun stuff
yeah and I could see you dropping the
kids off oh no I didn't tell you a
classroom or teachers you get out of the
car and the schools on lockdown well
it's it's great to see I hope you enjoy
me Friday you came in it was really good
I gave him a bottle of vodka as a gift
he open up the bottle of vodka I thought
that was a sign of you know drink man no
it was a hey here's a bottle like a
souvenir bottle why would you give me a
bottle here sitting down in a bar if you
didn't want me to drink it I didn't
think you were gonna drink it now or
open it that's that's a Breaking Bad
Heisenberg [ __ ] Jess really good it's
clean well appreciate it yeah we're glad
to have you in for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]